And now it's time for the much
heralded #HashtagWars.
(cheering and applause)
Tomorrow's St. Patrick's Day, a
day dedicated to drinking and
assuming every redhead is Irish.
Uh...
(laughter)
That's a photo from redditer
LilRedWoodPecker of a T-shirt
featuring Scotland's national
motto.
The only problem with St. Pat's
Day is by the time everyone's
drunk enough to start singing,
the only Irish song they can
remember is Danny Boy, and
maybe, maybe that YouTube song
from the Batman Forever
soundtrack.
You guys remember that one?
Nope? All right.
No Irish people here, I guess.
No Irish people.
But we're here to help with, uh,
tonight's hashtag,
#MakeASongIrish.
Examples might be "Uptown
Drunk," and "Me neck, me back,
me pussy and me Lucky Charms."
(laughter and applause)
Let's put 60 seconds on the
clock and begin.
Yassir.
>>"Kiss From a Rosacea."
>> HARDWICK: Yes, points.
Melissa.
>> "I Want to Riverdance With
Somebody."
>> HARDWICK: Yes, points.
Yassir.
>> "Baby Got Back-To-Back DUIs."
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
Melissa.
>> "In Da Pub."
>> HARDWICK: Yes, points.
Yassir.
>> "We Famine, Famine, Famine,
Famine." Yes!
>> HARDWICK: Points.
>> Some of you got it.
>> HARDWICK (Irish accent):
Those potato famine wounds are
still fresh.
(regular voice): Scott.
>> ♪ IRA rock, IRA island.
>> HARDWICK: Yes, points.
Yassir Lester.
>> "Shake Ya Lass, Watch
Yourself."
>> HARDWICK (laughing): Yes.
>> I got you, I got you.
>> HARDWICK: ♪ Shillelagh what
you're made of. ♪
Points to Yassir Lester and
points to me.
Scott Adsit.
>> "Girls Just Want to Have Nine
Kids."
>> HARDWICK: Points.
(laughter and applause)
Scott.
>> "Papa Was a Blarney Stone."
>> HARDWICK: Yes, points.